bruno selle
le nom et le bon soir ni mathy alain
lipietz thomas dutronc alors da bruno
roussel c'est l'ancien directeur sportif
de l'équipe de cyclisme festina
aujourd'hui vous êtes reconverti dans
l'immobilier en bretagne et vous publiez
un livre qui s'appelle tour de vis chez
hachette littératures vous savez comment
on fait bien alors donc tour de ville
chez hachette littératures bas tout de
suite on y va interview vérité en la
bouche pendant le jean galle
[Musique]
on ne bouge pas pendant le single
bien alors pendant le procès festina
faisait assumer la responsabilité
vous avez reconnu le dopage mais voilà
le problème c'est que rien n'a changé et
cette fois vous c'est sûr les dirigeants
et les organisateurs que vous mettez la
pression vous les mettez en cause
vous dites par exemple en parlant du
patron de l'union cycliste
internationale qui s'appelle verbruggen
vous dites quand verbruggen dit qu'il ya
des problèmes dans le tour d'italie le
giro il dit c'est un incident de plus il
oublie de dire qu'il conduit le bus
depuis des années au final mans
effectivement ce n'est beaucoup pris il
ya trois ans aux coureurs
vous vous dites que oui les coureurs ce
ne sont que des victimes finalement et
que si on est courageux
c'est aux dirigeants du cyclisme
français international qu'il faut s'en
prendre
effectivement je dis ici nous sommes
tous responsables de nos actes et les
coureurs les premiers au premier degré
au second degré y sont victimes d'un
système victime d'une faillite totale de
ce qui avait le mandat de la lutte
antidopage et qui en minimisant le
problème depuis des décennies n'ont fait
que conforter les cyclistes dans la
continuité de pratiques illicites et
c'est bien la faillite de tout un
système aujourd'hui qui est révélé ouais
alors question dopage
vous dites que le rsr 13 à remplacer le
perron donc finalement bon voilà il ya
plus de paix obama y en a un truc
nouveau qui est encore plus indétectable
de toute façon vous dites que dans le
dans le milieu du cyclisme dopage c'est
presque une gloire dire que les anciens
se raconte comme ça à la veillée les
histoires de dopage a tu te souviens
quand on est pris un pot belge ans était
à c'était bien marrer tous donc ça fait
partie c'est culturel l'ado enfin le
dopage chez les cyclistes est quelque
chose de tout à fait normal quoi
alors là on touche quelque chose de
culturel effectivement et puis d'un peu
dramatique c'est de banaliser ces choses
là le soir à la veillée ans l'ancien ne
fait que effectivement enlever toute
forme de
de prise de conscience et de culpabilité
éventuelle
des cyclistes c'est à dire comment
voudrait-on que des fils spirituels
prennent conscience de leur erreur si
les pères se glorifie de leur vie quoi
voilà c'était comme le fils de rouge
chez les mineures donc tant en quoi
c'est à dire tout le monde boit son
petit mitron là c'est pareil on se fait
ça au petit shoot de p o
ça fait partie du ça fait partie du truc
quoi ces juges se trouve
j'étais mineur un moment et c'est vrai
qu'il ya une espèce de façon d'obliger
les jeunes à accepter l'inacceptable par
des rites de passage comme ça voilà donc
vous parler de la doc mais ce qui est le
plus étonnant dans votre bouquin est un
bon l'accent a beaucoup été mis là
dessus ces derniers jours mais c'est
vrai que c'est très étonnant parce que
nous pauvres mortels on connaissait
l'histoire du dopage dans le cyclisme on
savait pas quelle est la corruption
moi je savais pas du tout ça c'est un
truc que j'ai appris en lisant votre
livre par exemple virenque a acheté 100
mille francs
sa victoire sur l'allemand jan ullrich à
courchevel dans le tour de france 97
ça c'est un truc qu'on ce n'est pas que
vous avez révélé hier que non seulement
il au fond que six achète les uns les
autres c'est penser au foot
comment ça s'est passé là donc ils sont
tous les deux faire raconter nous
racontez nous la le moment où il lui
fait comme ça quoi
je voudrais préciser avant que
contrairement à ce qui a été présenté il
ya quelques jours on a voulu enfin une
certaine presse a voulu faire une
affaire ou mba bis repetita je voudrais
rétablir un peu les choses c'est à dire
qu' il n'y a pas eu de match acheté au
départ il ya une belle bagarre ce jour
là ouais
on a mis l'équipe donc l'équipe festina
mis l'équipe telekom à genoux toute la
journée et les deux champions se sont
livrés une belle bataille mais il est
vrai et vous doutez bien que si je les
écris s'exhaler éléments il ya eu
entente entre les deux coureurs dans les
derniers kilomètres et on voit ce geste
qui est un des éléments
fait ça et même s'il ya d'autres mecs de
l'équipe qui disent enceinte aurait pu
attendre qu'ils aient pas de caméra pour
faire ça parce que là franchement tout
le monde tu as vu donc alors ça fait
partie un peu des us et coutumes je dis
pas que ça se produit à chaque fois mais
effectivement là c'est le même phénomène
j'ai eu à le dire jean marie leblanc le
premier en 1971 dans les 4 jours de
dunkerque a vendu ses services pour
l'équivalent d'un tiers de son mois de
salaire à l'équipe de roger de vlaeminck
donc une équipe
effectivement dans ses mémoires dans son
autobiographie le patron du tour de
france actuelle leblanc dit lui
effectivement il ay là il a roulé pour
de vlaeminck pour 2020 c'est à dire non
mais ça le piano des exemples qu'on va
pas citer parce qu'elle a beaucoup mais
ça veut dire que la corruption c'est à
dire c'est courant dans ses quelque
chose qu'on savait pas nous arrive
effectivement le pire c'est qu'ils il
dit en 99 c'est qu'il n'est pas choqué
voilà qu'encore une fois la fille
spirituelle que peuvent-ils penser il
faut comprendre aussi que pour les gens
du milieu
le mot correct corruption ne convient
pas tellement c'est à dire pour les
personnes dans la rue effectivement
c'est une corruption
là ça s'appelle dédommagement pour
victoire manquer quoi ouais voilà c'est
s'aider us et que tu meures produits de
décennie en décennie qui fait qu'il ya
une espèce de banalisation et qui
déculpabilise l'individu comment ça se
passe nous n'aurons satire qui lui fait
ça l'autre c'est d'accord donc je vais
tc gagner tu vas me filer du pognon mais
ils n'ont pas le temps étant sur des
vélos de discuter de mon temps non ça se
fait pendant la course associés pendant
la course et du fait comme ça comme ça
donc l'autre dit il doit quelque chose
et le lendemain c'est vous qui allez
maintenant oui sur un parquet je
rencontre quelqu'un
membre proche d'eux
de jan ullrich et qui me donne le
montant de la somme ils vous disent et
ce en mai et vous vous dites je vais
quand même demandé à virenque mais c'est
vrai que sans ville pour une victoire
comme ça c'est pas si cher que ça par
rapport à l'enjeu et à l'événement
effectivement j'ai pas été choqué à ce
moment-là douala de la somme de cent
mille autres ça c'est discuter entre
coureurs
moi j'apprends l'information après
effectivement on donne une somme si elle
paraît raisonnable par rapport à l'enjeu
elle et elle est acceptée et les deux
coureurs s'arrange après est ce que
disent et y rsa versé des sommes qui
sont pratiquement oui au départ des
courses kéké banide normalement sans
trucage nous il faut que j'aie jamais
dit ça il ya plus de courses à la
régulière qu'il y à deux courses acheter
d'ailleurs les us et coutumes aurait
voulu que ce jour là le maillot jaune en
seigneur laisse la victoire d'étape à
son veillant à son vaillant dauphin
récurrence richard ça c'est des us et
coutumes et c'est pour ça que l'on dit
d'ailleurs si un seigneur il a fait
preuve il a été magnanime envers richard
ouais pourquoi lui ce jour là at il
voulu
monnayer je n'en sais rien il est jeune
il était temps
c'est un allemand de l'ex rda peut-être
d'une génération où il est pas encore
imprégné de toutes cultures et il a
dérapé déjà que je voulais dire quelque
chose je voulais seulement dit à moi que
j'aime beaucoup le sport cycliste et il
peut se passer certainement plein de
choses que monsieur roussel connaît lieu
probablement qui compte
je mets que je m'étonne simple je
m'étonne un petit peu je me donne un
petit peu que monsieur roussel qui était
le patron de vie rentrent dans cette
fameuse étape a trouvé ça formidable
le jour de l'arrivée du tour de france
est la plus à trouver sa sensationnelle
il a partagé la victoire de vie rente
j'ai un peu surpris que quelques années
après ce sens des états d'âme non il a
été donné
hussein a été jugée tout ça qui ont été
condamnés vous avez vous appris de la
prison avec sursis vous a été condamné
une amende
et puis après ils auraient pu revenir
comme bernard tapie n'aurait pu revenir
dans le système du dsce crise
simplement ce qu'il est en train de
faire roussel c'est qu'ils brûlent ces
vaisseaux c'est à dire qu'il est en
train de faire une politique de terre
brûlée parce que bien évidemment après
ce qu'il dit là il restera dans
l'immobilier en bretagne retournera
jamais en six ans parce qu'il était
terriblement le règlement de compte et
je trouve que le livre qui sort juste
avant le tour de france tout ça c'est
lent c'est rien ça mais ça me laisse ça
me laisse un goût douteux à tous les dix
mois complet à tous les cas de figure
j'ai maintenant mais j'aime pas trop ça
voilà
éteignez la lumière
du tout bruno roussel est ce qu'il ne
s'agit pas tout simplement d'un
règlement de comptes
non c'est un retour aux sources pour moi
j'étais un éducateur et aujourd'hui je
suis beaucoup mieux dans ma peau que je
ne l'étais et j'assume parfaitement ce
que j'ai écrit et d'ailleurs je suis pas
à venir le défendre et il argumenté
devant qui que ce soit les high des fois
comme ça c'est très inattendu on peut
avoir la question qui tue faites
attention vous quand vous serez
président de la république vous l'aï dit
c'est une question qui tue c'est l
inattention je voudrais juste rajouter
une jambe
la loi du silence c'est la pire et en
écrivant ce livre effectivement j'ai
clair sur des moeurs et des pratiques et
la seule question qui à mon avis mérite
d'aider battue c'est quel sport
voulons-nous pour demain en fait c'est
celle là
et est ce que
pour nos enfants nos petits enfants est
ce qu'on souhaite que les coureurs
cyclistes
jacques y aura peut-être un petit fils
ou un arrière petit fils qui va faire du
vélo est ce qu il veut que son petit
fils ou son arrière petit fils
ils vivent ce que vivent aujourd'hui les
cyclistes alors on peut dire
effectivement bruno roussel etc
il a plein de défauts mais bruno roussel
aujourd'hui il dit qu'il a dit la vérité
et pour moi c'est un retour aux sources
et j'ai voulu éclairer quelque chose
beaucoup moins effectivement que richard
le débile c'est pas tellement richard
j'ai voulu attaquer dans ce livre c'est
la faillite des institutions
oui alors suite à votre bouquin virant
que richard virenque que lui ni il dit
j'ai jamais acheté cette victoire ulrich
nies aussi mais effectivement willy
woeth ex soigneur de virenque donc de
l'équipe festina dit le soir du massage
donc il parle avec virenque et lui dit
mais tu aurais pas acheter le victoire
n'a pas payé quand même et à ce
moment-là virenque dit willy veux tu lui
réponds si donc ça fait un témoin alors
on apprend même dans votre bouquin que
jean claude killy et pourtant pour nous
ayons produit à 6 emplois non
jean-claude comme je sais je sais bien
si jean claude killy
il sort pas indemne des révélations de
bruno roussel le 11 juillet 98 quand
will i ve de vient d'être arrêté avec le
coffre plein de seringue et de p o
il reçoit bruno roussel en compagnie de
jean marie leblanc qui est le patron du
tour de france et qu'il y dix ans à
ussel merde bruno pourquoi tu nous a pas
prévenus avant ça veut dire quoi
ça veut dire que si vous les aviez
prévenu avant il aurait pu arranger le
coup je me suis posé la question je me
suis sans doute trompé
et donc
je pense que il était lui aussi pressé
de questions par les journalistes il
devait il devait avoir à répondre de
cette voiture de la société du tour qui
inquiète mais c'est vrai qu'après cet
entretien je me suis posé la question
le doute s'est installé dans mon esprit
mais bon ici sûrement trompé
tu dois savoir tous les droits du livre
ont une association anti dopage ou un
truc comme ça c'est pour vous alors j'ai
reçu un à valoir
c'est à dire ce qu'on appelle une avance
et je les ai je les ai prises et sont à
100 pour moi j'ai pas pris de décision
par rapport à effectivement si c'est
vraiment pour dénoncer faudrait que ça
serve à quelque chose
pardon
bruno selle tour de vis
c'est chez hachette littératures et
c'est plaindre des nations pour être sûr
de ne rien rater de dinars 10 tubes
abonnez vous il m'était impossible eux